1964 le cinéaste aux québécois gilles
groulx sort son film le chat dans le sac
[Musique]
m
l'histoire d'une rupture amoureuse dans
le style nouvelle vague française avec
une trame sonore composée par nul autre
que john coltrane
[Musique]
le réalisateur feng de jazz est allé en
personne rencontrée le grand
saxophoniste dans un studio du
new-jersey il en est reparti avec un
enregistrement de 37 minutes
un enregistrement inédit jusqu'ici la
session ont été enregistrés sont entre
braine aussi à l'encontre elle n'avait
pas le temps accordé pour pour ce type
d'enregistrement l'a donc sa venue entre
deux heures entre 14 heures et 17 heures
le 24 juin
donc c'est tout et j'ai le goût est
parti ensuite avec l'enregistrement donc
la bande maîtresse de cet enregistrement
la qui a atterri dans les archives de
louannec y rester pendant plus de 55 ans
c'est grâce à cette employée de l'office
national du film du canada frédéric sa
part que cet enregistrement peut
maintenant sortir en disque
il a fallu cinq ans de négociations avec
les héritiers du musicien et une poule
free cordes qui détient son catalogue
pour que les bandes découverte au début
des années 2000 puisse légalement être
rendu public
comme j'ai vu que certaines personnes
prétendent est en ligne que les
enregistrements avait disparu alors que
c'était tout à fait faux c'est devenu un
peu une mission pour moi de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse libérer ces
enregistrements la dévote de l'onef pour
qu'elle soit entendue partout dans le
monde et pour que la vision de gilles
groulx soient reconnus parce que pour
moi c'est quand même assez significatif
qu'un québécois en 64 réussi à
convaincre jazzmen de la trempe de john
coltrane à faire une trame sonore pour
son fils
la rencontre entre les deux hommes
restent très mystérieuses ont-ils
développé une amitié une complicité
intellectuelle coltrane at il aussi été
attirés par l'appât du gain facile
les 37 minutes de musique enregistrée ce
24 juin 1964 ont été payées cash et ne
sont pas une composition originale du
musicien
cette musique là ce sont cinq thèmes
qu'on connaissait déjà qu'il avait déjà
enregistré
il ré improvise sur des thèmes qu'on
connaît like sony vient du blues naïma
of the world
et donc c'est une note en bas de page de
la vie ont rencontré mais c'est une note
en bas de page forte intéressante
un enregistrement qui peut donc
maintenant être ajoutés à la
discographie du légendaire saxophoniste
et c'est catherine françois radio canada
montréal
[Musique]